[Music]
lavelle starts us off in raleigh north
carolina
hi lavelle how are you i'm doing great
how about yourself
better than i deserve what's up
um i had a question for my uh car
um that i purchased and i wanted to
um didn't know if i should sell it or if
i should
uh just just keep going just keep going
with it until it's paid off
when did you purchase it um so i
purchased it probably about
four or five four to five months ago
okay and what do you owe on it
um i owe 18 000. what's your household
income uh
45 45 000. are you married
no i'm not single okay is that your only
vehicle
yes sir it is how much other debt do you
have other than your house
um i have about seven thousand left in
student loan debt and um a thousand uh
dollars left at the uh credit at my
credit union for our personal loan
okay well christy here's the principle
that
we always use on this okay a car
level is the largest thing we all buy
that goes down in value
another way of saying that it is the
largest wealth destructor
in our lives it destroys more of our
wealth than anything else
does that make sense yes sir because
it's the most expensive thing we buy
that goes down in value
i mean if you buy a thousand dollar tv
and four years later throw it in the
backyard no big deal
it didn't change your life but when you
take a 25 000
car or 20 000 car and turn it into a 6
000
car which is what they always do right
then you have destroyed
a lot of wealth per dollars wise does
that make sense
yes sir and yet we all love cars i got
cars i'm a car guy i want you to have i
don't want everybody to drive a junker
the rest of their lives
but you need to understand that ratio
wise the more
crap you own that goes down in value the
harder it's going to be to become
wealthy
so based on that idea the principle that
we developed or the concepts that we
developed are two
number one can you be 100 debt free not
counting your house
inside of two years and keep the car
this is assuming you love the car and
are willing to
fight scratch and claw to keep the
stupid thing do you do you lavell do you
love it
um i actually don't i actually have a
buyer for it um that that wants to buy
it next week i've
put it on the auto trader and why did
you put it on auto trader
um because i wanted to i wanted to get
out of
i wanted to get out of bed and maybe get
a cheaper car maybe pay cash for a car
and go through my
um credit union okay and possibly get
the loan to pay off the difference and
you know maybe get a little extra to you
know two or three thousand extra to
pay the car okay good to get a cash card
yeah
get you a cash card okay that's a plan
go do that go do that
i think you've got i think you've got a
great plan i don't want to stop you from
doing your plan
it's a plan that i probably would do if
i woke up in your shoes let me finish
giving you the principles
for the rest of our listeners sake and
because you might apply them at some
other
point okay number one we have to be
debt-free
inside of two years or the car has to go
you could pull that off it'd be a lot of
hard work but you could pull that off
you got 26 thousand dollars in debt you
make 40 you could work an extra job live
on beans and rice rice and beans and be
debt-free in two years
it could be done okay but you're not
going to i understand but i'm just
saying mathematically
that's doable the second thing is is the
is all the things that you own with
wheels and motors because everything
with wheels and motors goes down in
value
and again i've got a lot of stuff at
wheels and motors i'm not against having
it
i'm just against it having you i'm
against you being owned by this crap
they all go down in value and when you
add them all up do they equal more than
half your annual income if they do you
have too much
juice tied up in things that are
destroying your wealth instead of
building your wealth
and so you know people call me up i'm
making five thousand dollars a year i
got a fifty thousand dollar truck
well you might be a redneck if you know
that's just that's just stupid and that
principle applies whether it's uh
paid for even if it's paid for is that
what you're saying exactly yeah
see level you got things you know a 50
000 truck is going to be worth 25
about 20 seconds about 20 seconds i mean
it doesn't take long at all
no no one thinks about that about the
fact that the car i like how you just
said that
cars are the most expensive things we
buy that go down in value i mean like
when you say you're like yeah that makes
sense but no one
looks at cars that way they look at it
like hey i got a raise let me go get a
bigger car
they don't look at it as this thing that
is two steps forward three steps back
when it comes to building wealth
and i think that's important i like that
you pointed that out yeah when you
when you put 50 000 in the middle of the
table and over a series of
four years you burn most of it with a
match yeah
that's a problem yeah it's just for
unless you unless you make 150 000 then
you can survive that
but it's still a problem i mean i own
cars that are expensive today yeah
but just for the used car i mean just
for the new car smell that lasts about a
month
go get you some air freshener right yeah
like
losing that amount of money for a new
car for that very
short term feeling when it drops i mean
gosh that just it drops so quickly in
value
and tom stanley discovered this the
first time i read it was in 1992.
uh he wrote the book the millionaire
next door
and he one of the things he discovered
in his research of millionaires which we
have done our own research these days
but and that was the first time i ever
heard
it was the typical millionaire drives a
two-year-old or older car because i had
this thing that rich people all drive
nice cars and the truth is that a
certain level of rich
does right but until you've got a
million dollars in net worth buying a
brand new car
is mathematically stupid yeah now you
can do it and get away with it
but it's just stupid well even after you
have a million dollars net worth
you still look at cars differently
because the principles that got you to
that net worth or the principles you
want to maintain
not to your point not that you can't get
a new car but you're going hey i could
get one that's two years old it's
depreciated
fifty percent of its value and i'm going
to maintain the value longer yeah like i
said i got
i got several vehicles with boats and
sea doos
and you know side by side on the farm
and
i'm i collect i'm yeah i'm like a
grown-up boy you know i collect
things that go wood and wooden you know
i mean and so but but when i
i'm constantly running that factor and
going all of these things added together
need to be a
very small percentage of my world
because they're
all just sitting here rusting down to
nothing
yeah money wise meanwhile i could have
taken the same money and put in
something goes up in value which would
give me more to give
and more to do with yeah